In lesson one, you saw a relationship between Height and Hand Length. And you
used my Hand length, 6.75 inches, to guess my height. Based on this, you
probably guessed that I'm not more than six feet, or 72 inches tall. But what
if the data looked like this instead? Could we make a good guess about how tall
I am? Not really. What makes this data have a stronger relationship than the
other one? And what's one way to measure it? First of all, we can see if
there's a direction to this relationship. This is probably true in personal
relationships, too. In statistics, the direction of a relationship refers to
how the y variable changes as x gets larger. In the case of Height and Hand
Length, what happens as x, or Hand length, increases?